feels good feels like coming home yeah
it's almost exactly a year since I was
last here we wade through the slurry of
bat guano looking for snakes all right
first one to find a pipe and winds but
the next thing we find is not a giant
snake flatworms that cannot be good many
species of flatworm are parasitic I
guarantee this thing burrow into human
flesh and bad things happen inside the
human body probably all up in our nether
regions right now I wish I hadn't seen
man
I start having flashbacks to the last
time I was here this is it right here
that's where I saw the snake right here
and guess what I spot a big Python
behind the ridge around
let me see if I'm getting by the head
careful I'm not grabbing him by the tail
the reason I got bitten last time was
because when we grabbed the tail we
didn't have control of the head I'm not
making that same mistake the sleekness
ticks on its head this means that the
snake is left the cave and that's
something I really want to try to
determine are these snakes living out
their entire lives in the cave
are they exiting ticks can't survive in
decay so they prove this snake has been
outside those relics every time the
snake sheds his skin it will lose these
ticks so we know that this snake has
been outside the cave in the last month
or so
it supports Mark's theory that bigger
snakes like this exit the cave to hunt
they need bigger prey there's bats
inside they'll even hunt domestic
animals as big as pigs and goats he's
really squeezing I mean even a snake
this size somebody can't cut off my
circulation on my arm really a bore
snake here
really really strong imagine what it
would be like to tackle a snake 20 feet
long this is up three meters really the
9 or 10 feet long yeah I'm telling you
I've been I've been working in the field
as a herpetologist for 20 years it's
been a lot of that time in Southeast
Asia where reticulated pythons are found
and I have never found one in the wild
except in this cave we've been in here a
total of about 10 minutes and we already
caught about a 9 or 10 foot reticulated
pythons kidding we measure the snake for
Mark's research then release it and
continue our hunt for giant